hi everyone it's Jerry this is video two
from the improve your chest rating
playlist
I'm going to play another
15-10 game
insta player rated 1410
from Portugal okay
let's meet D4 head on
D4 D5 game a ram structure to begin
all right
not interested in playing a Queen's
Gambit accepted so
I'm gonna support my center with one of
these two
let's go with
um let's go with E6
yeah let's go with these six
so with E6 you know I may have a little
bit more trouble getting my light Square
Bishop out
one of the differences with these
I still keep the diagonal open
with C6
all right
I think I like this idea
more pressure on D5 more defense
where's this guy gonna go
F4 and G5
and G5 it is so I am in a pin
what's running through my mind is first
the breaking of the PIN
and really not too much more
I could question the bishop but I prefer
to have my Bishop on E7 first
and then maybe question with H6
I'd prefer to have maybe my queen on F6
or my Bishop on F6 rather than my queen
okay let's simply break the PIN
I think white does well to keep this
tension
releasing it too soon then this guy
could come out and about
all right Knight to F3 so with this last
move one of the ideas
uh for white
and regarding a central expansion it's
no longer there
with the Knight already committed to F3
so I think E3 may have been a bit more
flexible
bringing the bishop out and then still
keeping open the option for the king
Knight to go to F3 or E2
when it's on E2 this is the central
expansion I'm referring to F3 and D4
so I don't have to worry about this sort
of
Pawn Mass
getting set into motion
it's a healthy move
Knight F3
Okay so
candidate moves castles
um I don't think I want to capture on C4
here either
I keep this guy around
probably simply Castle
E3
Rook to C1 healthy I'd be going with E3
here
still don't think it makes sense to
release the tension so
all right so now how am I going to
complete Queen side development is a
question
um I could consider playing Knight to E4
or maybe right about now I think
I think maybe now I should question the
bishop
and after it backs off maybe then dive
into E4
okay so let's say after H6 Bishop H4
94. we're gonna have several exchanges
let's say Bishop takes Queen takes
Knight takes Pawn takes Knight D2
and I could play with
E5
there may even be some moves with Queen
B4 check
depending on where this Knight goes if
he goes into E5 but no not so much
Queen D2 is a fine reply
defending everything defending B2
all right I think I'm gonna go with H6
expecting the bishop to back off to H4
so this is one of those moves you have
to be way a little a little care a
little more carefully when white is
still on castled
um like there may be some fishing pole
type ideas with H4 here
it's super committal
but you know this Rook would spring to
life if I'm taking the piece all right
so we don't have the bishop staying
on this diagonal so that this one is
a little bit different for me to be
seeing
I'm I'm thinking now that I could try
and hunt the bishop so Knight to H5
maybe acquire the bishop pair
Knight H5 Bishop E5
could challenge it again
I think I'm gonna try for this Knight to
H5
something that is concerning me though
after Bishop to e if Bishop E5 is played
and then I let's say go after the bishop
Knight to C6 I normally wouldn't want to
do this but
I do have to watch over D5 if my knight
is
going off into space here on the edge
it's no longer around defending D5
so let's say this this Knight C5
and white simply develops and I take
Pawn takes my knight on H5 is a little
stranded with F6 under control by a pawn
so
I think I could
Maybe
still run a test like this here this and
if the bishop
is deployed
maybe I could return with my knight to
F6
um yeah I think I'm gonna try for this
going hunting
proceed with caution
it is unprotected so it's tactically
vulnerable
some night hops
at some point unleash the the monster
so where's this guy gonna go is the
question
might just sit there back off
this is frequently my knee-jerk reaction
to pressure on the bishop
the reason well if you're capturing this
Rook has at least helped
there's also the train of thought of
allowing the bishop to be captured on
this square and then key in on the big
intersection Square on E5
that's some great support
on E5 with
pawns on F4 and D4 but at the same time
this guy may become isolated so
as an example Bishop D3 I could take
and then take here and there you go
an isolated d-pawn
is on board so
we'll see what white comes up with
I'm thinking this is considered best in
this position we'll see after the game
what other moves might white be
considering here
okay so Bishop to D3 so I'm I'm guessing
I am gonna go for this idea to saddle
white with an isolated Pawn
uh I think it makes sense to swipe this
bishop while I still can
it may just be that these two are
interchangeable
I don't think white has anything better
than to be recapturing in these squares
so
uh I think I just swing the back
completely around at this point
I said a
with Knight H5 got to say B
for it to make sense
no there may be these ideas to try and
form a battery but
no not so much because this move is
going to pull
the bishop off the diagonal and I think
I do want to go with that
yeah
let's start with
the capture on C4
[Music]
yeah I think so
let's chop
some other move
okay maybe I don't I'm not sure what
else I was maybe considering keeping it
on this diagonal possibly
okay so here I do have now
after hunting that guy the bishop pair I
have an unopposed Bishop
what
part of the board is black maybe
sensitive on what dark squares could I
maybe key in on
at the same time I am significantly
underdeveloped than the queen side
so moves that run through my mind are
ones that put pressure on D4 flank Pawn
attacking the center Pawn
as well as moves like this to Simply
complete development
want to be careful about this open
diagonal
I'm expecting this Knight to dive in
here soon
this guy's a bit stuck
okay if I play with C5 I'm guessing
I'm guessing D5 is a good reply
hmm
D5 takes and if Knight takes I think I
may be just come into the C6 Square
I may end up losing this guy back
after something like this but when this
Pawn is making capture at least this is
helping my Bishop to finally develop
I think this is the correct start
also helps my queen
yeah let's put pressure on the center
helps out the queen have a open diagonal
so Queen A5 might be a move at some
point
Knight C6
now that my C Pawn is contributing
this does undermine a support point of
the Knight on E5
so not not so easy to run right in
to E5 with the pressure on D4 now
some of I always have to be on the
lookout for is
this one to disrupt this structure and
extend the scope of my Bishop
so
just making some dummy moves on White's
end if let's say after 95 I went with
Rook there
then you could see F5 hitting
right if I take then there's a problem
on F7 we could see the
it's not long off
uh where white could be coordinating on
one of my
squares near the king
so I don't think I would want to play
Rook to yay but just highlighting a a
way we could see the white pieces
intersecting in my camp
these three could somehow play a role on
F7
so what is white considering castles is
probably fine keeping the tension this
one this one
I would not mind a queen Exchange
okay so D5 is played I think this is
probably one of the better moves
so we're gonna have some exchanges now I
mean the King still is in the center so
I was pointing out that these guys are
still back home
uh and and that that move I was just
discussing with Rook to E8 that might
actually be a a good one to be getting
in here at some stage
the King still anyone
this guy is still in the way but okay
first things first I think I need to
start by capturing and
I guess let's just find out how White's
recapturing and go from there
I really don't want to allow the capture
on this Square
okay
so
now I could play this I'm really looking
at this square one of the
I mean there's there are many things I
could be
um
my mind is drawn to a lot of things in
this position because the structure has
changed significantly
I have a queen side majority
a healthy Queen side majority
um my three Queen side ponds could
create a passer
these guys that cannot against these
the big difference with this Pawn being
on F4 rather than
E3 is that it doesn't control D4 so D4
is a whole
so I'm looking at ways to secure a piece
on D4 and I think I'm close to doing
that
and having a knight be really strong on
this point
I should also mention that this is a
moment where I could
insert a check I don't think it's
anything great B4 seems like a move
that's going to hurt me
because this bishop would be hanging
with check
after the check is resolved
so this one this one
I think I'm gonna go with tonight here
my opponent also has checks
they aren't anything great in this
position but still
what I would like to see is Knight takes
Bishop
you get to recapture with check
maybe a coin exchange I would not mind
an ending at all
think white does well to Castle here
and in reply to castles
I'm thinking probably Bishop to F4
yeah
Bishop to F4
Bishop to F6 Knight to D4 a lot of my
attention in this position is on minor
piece play
it's on the dark squares D4
the moves that are going to increase my
control over this
weak Square
or weakest Square I think we can say in
White's camp
so this one
makes sense this one probably isn't a a
good idea because
then this is going to hurt
that much more or or even this move
first
within this idea then the knights
well it'll still be in a pin whether the
queen is on home base or E2 but
problem is is that with the queen on E2
this pin
you know Knight to D4 is going to hurt
that much more
okay
did not expect that one
well the first move that's crossing my
mind is Knight to H5 Knight to A5
tracking down the light Square Bishop
hmm
I don't know that I even want to go in
for that though
it's tempting okay also white is maybe
headed
Queen side
Knight A5
Queen here Knight takes Queen takes
there may even be Queen there something
happening
that could be tricky
hmm
I mean there's pressure here
I'm thinking I want to put my Bishop on
F6
first
something tells me I want to go for that
and maybe allow that light Square Bishop
to be
still be around
yeah let's put it on F6
Knight takes Queen is
fantastic on F6 nice Stable Square
developed
pressure on F4
not on any open or half open file so
okay
this one
so I don't think there's any wonderful
Discovery at the moment
you have to be careful any night move
there's a discovered attack against my
queen but all the forward moves are
covered only once
it's only when there's some kind of
intersection and let's say Knight to E7
where I'd be concerned
okay
I think I want to start with this one if
Queen there
could go Knight to A5 at that point
then I have IDs I would not mind now
that it's Queen side castles I wouldn't
mind losing my B Pawn
because then there's probably going to
be something bad happening on B2 for
white
I don't know if I really like this idea
Knight takes Pawn takes it seems like it
could be easily blockaded
some healthy moves
just to take make sure that pass Pawn is
under control
how to pick up the pace as well
okay
let's go with Bishop to G4
and see what y comes up with
could get a little messy
these sharper positions I would prefer
to not be down so much time
or really any position but
it's how it goes
all right
not sure what move White's going to come
up with here
I always question the bishop straight
away
I am from I am prepared to knock out the
night and hop into this Square this will
okay so that I'm pretty sure is an error
because I could take the Knight and
they're not really in a position to
recapture The Rook because this would be
a fork
I think I should do this right now
this is still maybe a move okay they are
walking right into
this Fork idea
this is
they ended up missing this idea
so
I guess at this stage we simply Bank the
material
get that Knight into D4
and at this point taking
on this Square
okay that capture first but I just get
to recapture and develop a piece and now
I have a lead in development
oh maybe maybe the idea
was to be able to go here and on Knight
takes Rook Queen takes but on this move
I think I do well
to play Rook B8 first
gaining a valuable Tempo against the
queen and then after let's say queen D5
then I take
and the big difference is that after the
recapture I'd immediately be on B2
so
I'm wondering about a different move
instead of night to Knight takes Rook
because
this guy right here is almost feels like
it's a rook
I I am no I was gonna say I'm down upon
I'm not down upon but some move that's
on my radar is B5
B5
I mean this one this one is gonna be
good most likely but after B5 let's say
Bishop takes then I have Rook to B8
threatening to win the bishop if it's
glued in there I have A6 Bishop takes
Pawn then I have that and then this is
collapsing
and I probably track down the rook in
the end too
I do have to be a little bit careful
about
some
tactics possibly on B7
also this this I have Rook there
and there's still a problem on these two
points so I think I'm gonna go with this
one
thank you
maybe even bother the queen a bit more
so this one this guy here I see you know
the night ponds and opposite sides
Castle's positions
I see them as Expendable Pawns
got these open lanes if they're no
longer around towards the enemy King
so we have two pieces hanging
there's no way to one of the checks I
did I didn't
voice it yet but one of the checks I did
was you know is there a way for The Rook
to move in this position and defend the
bishop there isn't
uh also okay this bishop is unprotected
this Square
and I think I could squeeze a little bit
more
out of this position maybe even to keep
in mind to have this as a possible check
that may show up
all right let's let's get this one in
I'm getting some valuable temp uh tempos
in her Tempe
valuable moves
this could maybe land with check
okay
Bishop is also unprotected okay I think
at this point though taking there
although The Bishop's ready recapture
now I could take on that forward check
okay I think I am ready right about now
to go ahead and win the material I'm
just looking for something that may be
better
not really seeing what may be better
clean B6
bothering the bishop not this one
um
I could maybe go for that still
trying to bug the bishop
see if I do play this one
yeah this and if I go there there's that
okay I think maybe now is the best time
to
go ahead and grab the Rook where or no
maybe maybe this move actually
that one
Queen takes this bishop takes check no
okay let's let's go in for the Rook
finally
spending a lot of time I'm trying to
find something better
I don't know if it's the best
practical decision but
okay
that Bishop's very good
to win this Pawn would check
don't know that I want to even do that
though
they want to defend on my queen side
Pawns
and look forward to some Pawn break here
like the check there I don't know
seems like the king is sneaking away a
bit
I don't want this guy to fall and there
to be a nice
safe Square for the king
defends a lot of squares I also have an
INF too
and this is
it's the win of upon with check but
my queen feels a little bit misplaced
I think I like this approach best
B4
C3
a5b4 B3 okay offering a queen exchange
so
don't mind going into the ending
I am undoubling the Pawns
that Bishop is really good
I don't think I want the queen exchange
no
I have the
I have the safer King
let's keep the Queens on as tempting as
it is to try and get the coins off I
don't I don't want to give my opponent
an inch
and I feel like I'm giving my opponent
an inch in undoubling the pawns and
maybe there's that formation this guy's
really good at defending the
second rank
King side
okay so now we have Rook lifts
maybe also just taking over control the
file
or even Pawn breaks probably be for you
this is a hook so
yeah I think I
play this one
clean there possibly
yeah let's get this in here clean to D5
yeah at that point maybe maybe I could
actually take
here here
maybe go right after the pawn
split these guys up possibly go after
this Pawn
do something on the B file yeah the B
file is going to now open up so
hmm
almost feels like a mouse lip unless
they're
going for some kind of caveman attack
okay
so I think I actually just keep pressing
like this create more tension
I think
two files are now likely going to open
up
the B and C
okay so now I have a healthy pick at
this point
Healthy Choice take on A3 with Chuck
and
where's the mate
oh here's the main check
I have to go there check
and then Checkmate on C2
okay
I got these covered this this covered
it's a main two from here
all right
all right typing a good game my
opponent's way
all right
let's
have a look at this one
let me click on the analysis
and while it's crunching the numbers
let's see what's going on with this
and change these settings real quick
I want to look at two lines always
see where there might be some only moves
overall I thought this was a really well
played by a really well played game by
my opponent
um where did it go wrong exactly I'm
thinking this point here Bishop E5
yeah better decision it could be made at
this stage
Bishop E5 or Bishop to G3 but to allow
the capture on F4
this is where there's a shift in the
evaluation
I believe
still crunching the numbers
still calculating moves there
let me do a
quick refresh
not sure why it's
there we go okay so what is it saying at
this point Bishop B5 Bishop G6
yeah so this was
better option also
Bishop H4
more standard and I I should be I should
be pointing this out this isn't uh this
isn't the greatest move that I'm going
with
I should be going with C5
saying
and either one of us could end up with
an isolated Pawn but to challenge it
right away
that is the suggestion I was drawn to
hunting a bishop
not best because of this and I I
intended Knight C6
this is my thinking but it's not really
liking that either
yeah this this bishop simply sits there
so if let's say the
I'm of like A3 if I'm taking I believe
we take with the pawn and this was my
concern
like getting stranded on H5 and it's
more than a concern it's considered
losing
so this was a wrong idea by me to go
hunting after the dark Square Bishop
better with C5
and for white better with Bishop to E5
so now we get this isolated Pawn
position where it's around evil even
and it stays even for just a few more
moves
I wonder if it's the queen side Castle
that it didn't like
or maybe Queen to B3 D5 is a good reply
to C5 best reply
Knight takes okay Queen takes Bishop
takes it like better one of the thoughts
I had I didn't Express in the game is
that after this I can't get to cease I
would be a little bit more concerned
about playing Knight to C6 here even
though it would be two Bishops versus
two knights I'm not really a big fan of
taking on these double isolated Pawns
still an evenish game but um
be different if I could already be here
and stop castle kingside castle but
not quite there
D5 is good
Knight takes now I do find it a little
bit easier to finally complete my
development
and it does go downhill
right after Queen B3 it says I have
Knight A5
95 Bishop F6
how's this one carrying out
I didn't think the pin would be so
difficult to get out of
I think this ran through my mind
you could get out of the pin with check
but yeah opposite sides castles there's
pressure here my queen
and Bishop I have the safer King is what
it's coming down to
this guy could act as a nice battering
ram as well
didn't look deep enough at that one
Knight F6 my focus was on D4
and it's considered already a a one
position for for black mostly because of
this weak Square on D4
gonna be able to plant a piece there
and they just had a Miss there
with Knight D4 hitting with a fork
unfortunately
it's ugly both ways if you're taking
like this
also the the bishop also could be glued
into D4
Knight A5 hunt this
a lot of ways to play it at this stage
now I was saying earlier about
opposite sides castles
in a way you wouldn't want to have your
knight Pawn but
if you're having triple isolated pawns
that's
there's something off with that one
so okay they ended up missing the fork
and it was B5 best
Lynx B5 best
and C4 C4
okay
once you have a knight to E2 okay at
this point I guess we can pick our
favorite way I want to keep Queens on in
the end and just break open files
let's go straight to mate
okay uh that's gonna do it for this one
in the end we have 95 accuracy for
myself 86 for my opponent
thought it was a well played game
overall just that middle game position
I was able to pounce on D4
and uh yeah
I'm gonna call it for this one Feel Free
as usual to leave any feedback in the
comments section below
hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away that's all for now
take care bye